[Musique]
cuba ces 6000 kilomètres de plage quasi
vierge
alors que les îles voisines des caraïbes
en accueille des dizaines de milliers de
touristes chaque mois cuba reste l'une
des destinations les plus préservés
les visiteurs sont peu nombreux
les étrangers qui s'installent ici
encore moins
c'est pourtant le choix qu'a fait
stéphane férus un agent de voyages
français
les plages incroyable
pratiquement personne pour l'instant
c'est quand même l'endroit le plus
authentique de de la caraïbe
à 46 ans il a passé la moitié de sa vie
à cuba
sa compagne à l'ina est originaire de la
havane sa fille est née ici
après des décennies d'isolement
stéphanois sont il s'ouvrir au monde
mon ami je le vois ici à cuba
a continué à avoir des
évolutions des emplois en cours ça va
pas s'arrêter comme ça et en miroir
jusqu'où ça va aller
on est très heureux à cuba on travaille
bien le tourisme se développe et la
famille aussi
moins de 500 français vivent ta cubain
parmi eux michel 67 ans
il ya six ans elle a quitté toulouse
pour
prendre sa retraite près de la havane
[Musique]
immergé dans la vie locale
quand j'ai trouvé toute cette chaleur
humaine comme j'ai trouvé ça
ça a été comme un aimant et j'y suis
resté
elle va accueillir un groupe de
touristes toulousain et tenter de les
convertir au charme de cuba
1 900 km à l'est de l'île patrick
teysseron et producteurs de cognac en
charente il vient trois fois par ans
explorait les contrées sauvages de cuba
en décembre je rentre en france pour six
mois
six mois et tu veux pas rester avec nous
oui on pourrait monter une affaire
ensemble
il s'est fixé une mission un peu folle
sauver l'héritage des tribus indiennes
qui peuplaient lille jusqu'au 15ème
siècle il ya une humanité ici à cuba et
je le dis et je le répète qui n'existe
plus ailleurs dans le monde donc ça je
vais les aider à mon petit niveau a
conservé sa
pour patrick stephan et michel cuba
c'est avant tout un voyage dans le temps
un patrimoine une atmosphère unique
qu'il tente de préserver
[Musique]
car au pays de la salle st une nouvelle
musique résonne
comme un air de changement
[Musique]
à 45 minutes de la havane le petit
village de mar bella prend chaque matin
un air provençal
ces deux ans le point
haut michel claverie a réussi à importer
ici quelques traditions de toulouse sa
ville natale
vous avez vu il n'ya que les femmes qui
marquent des points
allez rond le rôle rôle
c'est mes boules de pétanque que tu
viens de prendre
[Rires]
conscience fonctionnaire michel a
découvert cuba en 1988 lors d'un
chantier de solidarité
si le poids et pour nous séduite par le
pays elle s'est installé dans ce village
il ya six ans pour profiter de sa
retraite elle a vendu c'est bien à
toulouse pour acheter une petite maison
à 30000 euros
problème tout j'aime la culture j'aime
les rapports avec les gens
les sourires parce que le couvert quand
il a dû tirer de ces difficultés
vincent - michel et plus cubaine que
française parce qu'ici avec elle on
forme un groupe très soudé et avec cette
femme on partage tous les bons comme les
mauvais moments
tu danses allait
pas le temps de rester dense et
aujourd'hui elle va accueillir à
l'aéroport une famille toulousaine
qu'elle ne connaît pas mais qui a
entendu parler d'elle
michel valet guide et bénévolement comme
elle le fait souvent pour des
compatriotes en vacances
[Musique]
des amis d'amis
on me les envoie et des gens qui
connaissent pas du genre
le premier jour je suis bien aussi de
rencontrer quelques numéros pays
équiper leurs amis quel âge
par exemple le rythme de cuba
bonjour
alors quelles sont vos premières
impressions
que c'est inadmissible d'attendre dans
l'année pour récupérer les valises des
joueurs on a la première impression
khaled
michel va leur faire découvrir
l'histoire du pays et le quotidien des
habitants vous allez vous déplacer là
dedans aussi quant à la havane parce que
je pense que
la nuit à laval pour vous c'est pas
tellement
il vaut mieux que je vous ai dit que
bien ce que vous pouvez faire et vous
revenez dormir à la maison nous de ce
qu'on entend en france on s'est dit
avant que ce pays soit transformé
on va venir voir comment vivent vraiment
les gens
il est leur vie quoi
versata souris
il restait
pour cette première nuit là retraités
les accueille dans la modeste maison
qu'elle partage avec son compagnon
cubain roberto
[Musique]
comme beaucoup de cubains michel et
roberto vivre avec peu d'argent et les
moyens du bord mais tradition cubaine
oblige ils ont à coeur de séduire leurs
invités
merci
demain l'exploration va commencer
michel commence par les emmener dans le
sud de l'île au bord de la mer des
caraïbes
hors hydrocarbures il est ému parce
qu'il a vu l'eau transparente
ouais toujours
ici il y à 54 ans la cia a envoyé des
combattants tenté un coup d'état contre
fidel castro
les soldats cubains ont réussi à
repousser leur ennemi américain
[Musique]
o le cadre paradisiaque
le cadre la sef et des guitares
difficile d'imaginer qu'une bataille
roger s'est déroulée sur cette plage la
playa giron le 17 avril 1961
et donc le dise même si ce sens
dans les plaines il ya aussi les tories
et même si l'historique sur les pleurs
et c'est quand même c'est quand même un
moment la playa colonna a entendu parler
de la baie des cochons
c'est quand même important de le voir
un champ de bataille redevenu
aujourd'hui un lieu de plaisir
à l'eau voit ses pieds tout c'est
magique
le souvenir de l'affrontement avec les
états unis s'efface d'autant que depuis
quelques mois les deux pays se
rapprochent
cet avenir proche à court terme et à
moyen terme je le vois quand même avec
sérénité parce que je pense qu'on veut
garder
les valeurs de plus bas que ça change un
peu pro qu'ils aient plus de confort
peut-être un peu plus de facilités de
transport des choses comme ça il doit y
avoir des choses à améliorer et que ça
reste quand même ce petit côté nature
et ça c'est vraiment une richesse
une richesse que tous les français de
cuba ont à coeur de partager
[Musique]
la grande majorité d'entre eux vite à la
havane et travaillent dans le secteur du
tourisme
[Musique]
dans un faubourg de la capitale
stéphane l'agent de voyages et sa
famille occupe le deuxième étage de cet
immeuble
tant mieux tu as pris ton petit déjeuner
oui j'ai prix du lait j'ai pas le temps
là
60 m² pour trois personnes un luxe pour
la havane si la famille franco cubaine
mène aujourd'hui une vie confortable les
débuts ont été difficiles
là j'étais sur le point de faire mon
premier voyage à cuba
à 18 ans stéphane a quitté la france
pour sillonner le monde il s'est posé à
cuba après huit années de voyage est
tombé à mouvaux de ligne je me dis
souvent à mes 6 ans même si j'étais un
petit peu à
peu inconscient quand même il y avait un
côté un peu explorateurs cuba allait pas
sauver de ce grand choix par le tourisme
selon les dires dans les 200 prochaines
années et pour l'instant vingt ans après
c'est toujours ça y'a pas grand chose
d'autre
dans temps plus tard l'explorateur est
donc devenu guide touristique
experts de cuba même pour les cubains
il connaît les moindres recoins de la
vieille havane
combien de temps avec eux minois ici
et on met
ça
77 ans
depuis neuf mois le français forment de
jeunes cubains à devenir guide
touristique
qu'est ce que c'est ah
bah force pas seulement
cette formation est une petite
révolution car jusqu'ici les guides
cubain dépend des tous de l'état depuis
quelques années ils peuvent être
engagées par une entreprise privée comme
celle de stéphane
salord
faites-la vieri c'est un musée il ya
beaucoup de gens qui habitaient
parmi les élèves marie à 26 ans elle
s'entraîne devant ses futurs collègues
[Musique]
et on a fait la respiration est ce que
tu utilises les pancartes avant/après
l'a
classée au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco la place à vieira et ses
maisons coloniales du 16ème siècle ont
été rénovés vitrine du tourisme à cuba
la ville est aujourd'hui en pleine
reconstruction les guides petit à petit
à
avoir les relations des étrangers ils se
rendent compte
les français ou les européens
s'intéressent plus à certains thèmes
qu'à d'autres qui pour eux étaient
complètement sans intérêt donc ils vont
orienter leurs discours aussi en
fonction
parmi les thèmes qui intéressent les
touristes la vie quotidienne dans un des
derniers pays communistes du monde
mais
fodé capi et les typiques dans la vidéo
un pass
marty 2
social
les bodegas ont des magasins qui
appartient à l'état les produits sont
subventionnés donc bon marché mais les
achats sont rationnés
tous les produits et
la quantité que chaque personne
frais soit
et en tout
c'est par why
13h20 lycée
avec l'amélioration du niveau de vie à
cuba les habitants ont moins recours à
ces boutiques
ta apparaître un système un peu le cas
d'ubs et pourtant si à cuba à l'heure du
social à partir du piquant dans sa main
pleine évolution à cuba donc on ça va
disparaître un jour bientôt
les bodégas pourrait passer à la
postérité comme une étape folklorique
sur les circuits touristiques
regardez c'est typique du pays il a un
chapeau cubain et un cigare de la havane
cuba n'est jamais accueilli autant de
touristes ils veulent profiter de l'île
avant le changement 3 millions
d'étrangers ont visité le pays l'an
dernier il en attend deux fois plus
d'ici cinq ans
[Musique]
le pays peut-il réellement faire face à
cet engouement
au coeur du centre ville dans les
bureaux de l' agence de voyages de
stéphane la journée se poursuit avec son
lot de problèmes vos valises sont pas
arrivés hier soir face à
2 2 les petits détails d'organisation se
dire prends un taxi qu'est tombé en
panne moi j'ai eu beaucoup de mal ce
qu'on a des standards il faut que ça
évite moi c'est vrai que les français je
pense que et quand ça va pas vite ça
m'énerve et c'est vrai qu'elle n'a pas
dit mais si il faut déconnecter
complètement et c'est vrai que j'ai on a
du mal
paradoxalement l'afflux de touristes à
la havane devient pour stéphane un
casse-tête principal problème trouver
des places dans les hôtels ou les casa
particular les maisons d'hôtes
il manque de place il manque
d'infrastructures que ce soit un hôtel
on a le boulzec à sa particulière à cuba
depuis deux ans mais même ça suffit pas
la solution stephen va aller la chercher
loin de la capitale
le lendemain
des plantations de tabac des collines où
le temps semble s'être arrêté plus
le calme absolu ou prescrits
oui
un peu lauton devait été fait irruption
dans le paysage
on était 200 mhz intéressant avec des
pisteurs cuba stéphane repère un nouvel
itinéraire pour ses clients
franchement
des pythons calcaire qui datent de la
préhistoire aux pistes d'argile rouge ce
sera l'aventuré
prend pas son mieux pour bosser depuis
quelques mois ils cherchent des
activités pour ses clients à l'égard de
la havane déjà saturées de touristes
pour l'instant il n'y a pas beaucoup de
l'été à cuba
voir pratiquement rien et donc important
d'ouvrir des voies comme celle ci la
descente un des obstacles
voilà attiré nouvelles formes de
clientèle aussi
le message que perçoit le plus ici s'est
il faut combien avant que ça change donc
énormément de demandes c'est tellement
variés on a tellement le choix
entre la partie culturelle la nature
la mer comme il y avait comme
destination
et il y encore beaucoup à découvrir
[Musique]
à 900 km de la havane la région de
baracoa n'être accessible par la route
que depuis 1960
rares sont les étrangers qui viennent
jusqu'ici
c'est précisément ce qui attire patrick
teysseron
mais là
1 combien et le kilo de tomates à 30
centimes
donne moi un kilo et demi
patrick a découvert par hasard barre à
pau il ya 15 ans une des régions les
plus isolées de l'île
moi je m'adapte je fais comme les
cubains
quand y'en a pas j'en mange pas cherche
autre chose voilà tout le monde n'a
peut-être pas suffisamment à manger
tous les jours mais bon il ya une
solidarité ici qui fait que tout le
monde me réussit à bien manger quand
même
grands
producteurs de cognac en france il vient
ici trois fois par an
tu peut m'emmener sur le corner
[Musique]
patrick a fait de ce lieu préservé une
deuxième patrie
ce sont des gens qui ont peu ils
partagent tous faut une grande culture
et s'appelait quoi voilà donc je me sens
bien ici je relis
il n'est pas en vacances il a une
passion pour l'histoire des tout
premiers habitants de l'île des indiens
décimés par les conquistadors et oublier
des livres d'histoire à chaque séjour il
explore la région à la recherche de
vestiges de cette civilisation
il part aujourd'hui découvrir des
grottes dont cet ami lui a parlé
roberto c'est un archéologue très réputé
ici à cuba il a à peu près 30 ans de
fouilles sur la zone de bach à quoi et
des analyses de ces grottes est très
importante pour nous pour pouvoir
archiver en fait le patrimoine tainot
les taïnos c'est le nom de la tribu
indienne qui peuple et cuba avant
l'arrivée des colons
patrick va explorer ce qui fut leur
territoire et il a un autre projet
encore plus ambitieux
reconstitué dans les montagnes un
village indien
pour atteindre les grottes des indiens
taïnos il faut deux heures de route puis
une longue marche dans la forêt
tropicale
attention avec sa machette
regarde moi ça bien voir ce que j'ai
trouvé regardez il faut que tu vois ça à
l'intérieur de la grotte patrick
découvre des dessins réalisés il ya plus
de mille ans par les indiens on a
découvert un un visage il ya deux yeux
le nez la bouche une caractéristique
très importante on dirait des larmes
la largeur est combien 15 cm insee santé
maintenant
entre les deux yeux il ya combien
3 cm ok
on est en train de prendre toutes les
précautions à éviter que tout soit
altéré cette ligue 1 que ses dessins se
détruisent ou que ce qui est arrivé dans
les années 1800 arrive à nouveau quand
beaucoup de dessins de gravures ont été
volés sortie du pays
préoccupés par la préservation des sites
l'état cubain a laissé ce patrimoine à
l'abandon à plus de 1000 grotte autour
de baracoa n'ont encore jamais été
exploré je prends un autre photo oui
c'est bien
avec l'ouverture au tourisme le pays
commence à mesurer l'importance de cet
héritage
aujourd'hui les cubains sont en train de
redécouvrir leur patrimoine qui
demandent qu'à être publiés qu'à être
sorti de l'oubli
qui la mène tranquillement
nous allons prendre le chemin
qu'empruntaient les indiens taïnos
et pour aller au bout de ses ambitions
patrick troque sa chemise d'archéologues
pour celle de professeur le français
apprend aux enfants cubains leur propre
histoire mais la
regarder des milles ces pierres ont plus
de mille ans
c'est pierre là oui c'est ça mais écoute
bien camino c'est pierre forme est un
chemin qui allait de la cascade qui
servait de réservoirs d'eau aux indiens
montagne pour arriver jusqu'à leurs
villages sur le mirador nous allons nous
rendre
c'est plus facile de monter que de
descendre dans quelques mois patrick se
lancera dans son nouveau défi
[Musique]
allons sur le mirador
attention c'est dangereux il va édifier
un village indien sur les hauteurs de la
colline un des plus beaux sites de la
région
va s'arrêter là
regardez comme c'est beau ici
on va faire un petit village
sidious qui avait comme on dit si dieu
le veut avec des ateliers pour apprendre
aux enfants la céramique comme on
faisait des robes en coton donc c'est
important qu'ils viennent au départ de
ce projet là parce que je pense que
quand ils seront 18 20 ans certainement
y en a quelques-uns qui vont nous aider
à prolonger l'histoire
ken quinn qui a nié lundi était déjà
venu ici
à personne
parce qu'on ne savait pas que cet
endroit existe et s'il n'y avait pas eu
le projet de patrick ne serait jamais
venu là on n'aurait jamais voulu au sein
d'orama
moi je voudrais dire merci aux
professeurs c'est très gentil tout ce
qu'il a fait pendant
100 mots pas très qu'ils auraient pas
découverte ou safari il y aura peut-être
découvert un jour mais bon en disant que
c'était une façon
leur faire connaître un petit peu leur
environnement leur patrimoine
et puis sur tellement gentil tellement
super et s'intéressent ils ont soif
d'apprendre tout ça moi ça
ça me plaît et ça me donne de l'énergie
en plus et c'est la relève qui se
prépare à
l'hiver prochain patrick posera à cet
endroit les premières pierres de son
village destinés non pas à accueillir
des touristes mais à sensibiliser les
cubains à leur propre histoire
[Musique]
après les plages de rêve michel et ses
amis de toulouse découvre les marais de
cuba dans le parc naturel de zapata
l'athée réserve de biosphère par
l'unesco la lagune est réputé pour la
richesse de son écosystème
le plus exceptionnel des caraïbes
[Musique]
les indiens taïnos cher au coeur de
patrick vivait aussi sur ces petits
îlots il avait la tête
[Musique]
leur territoire est aujourd'hui un parc
à thème censé raconter l'histoire des
indiens bien éloignée du projet culturel
et éducatif de patrick
certains cubains essaient de profiter de
l'engouement pour leur pays en proposant
à la hâte de nouvelles attractions
j'ai vu le monsieur
déguisé sortir devant la porte et quand
il a vu la risée déjà il est rentré vite
prêt à se dit mon dieu j'ai dit enfin
son petit je dis on évitait allez on
fait le tour là bas je trouve que c'est
une pâle imitation de la réalité ah non
je n'aime pas du tout ce truc là
peut-être les gens demandent aussi il ya
certaines personnes qui le demandent
nous on ne demande pas à se construire
une authentique mais il ya des personnes
qui croient vraiment que des gens qui
peuvent voir et je crois je crois il ya
des gens qui aiment ça moi j'aime pas ça
du tout
retour donc à l'authentic cuba pour
michel et ses invités
elles les ont même passé la nuit chez un
ami qui louent les chambres de sa maison
génialissime la scène ce soir vous allez
prendre l'apéritif guinée écoutez de la
salsa et si vous êtes sympas goûter une
autre spécialité de cuba
sauf pour le petit garçon bien sûr
[Rires]
pour luis le propriétaire des lieux
accueillir des touristes est une
découverte
vous avez du crâne
et la du crocodile il a très longtemps
été interdit aux cubains de louer leur
maison à des étrangers
l'ouverture récente a aussi levé cette
barrière
alors que le salaire moyen est de 17
euros par mois loïs peuvent désormais
louer ses chambres 15 euros par nuit
pendant longtemps il y avait beaucoup
d'interdits mutsch police ya énormément
l'interdire et puis au fur et à mesure
floral ils ont été levées et appartenait
depuis quelques temps on peut vendre sa
maison
lapenta l os boittiaux de construit une
voiture y 14 et surtout on peut
aujourd'hui louis ses chambres à
l'autorité en plus pour les touristes
qui viennent ici c'est mieux parce
qu'ils voient comment on vit la personne
il dîne et parle avec nous et comprend
un hôtel c'est moins chaleureux depuis
quelques mois la maison d'hôtes affiche
tous les jours complets
[Musique]
non
pour les touristes toulousaine
la fin du séjour approche
et elles ont finalement adopté le rythme
cuba
dans leur maison d'hôtes elle termine
par un des incontournables de cuba la
soirée salsa
[Musique]
le montrer ça me faisait
plaisir et j'espère qu'elle le
profit
[Musique]